annual veterans day parade rolled
through downtown today after the
pandemic canceled the event last year
thousands of nevadans came out to
celebrate and say thank you to those who
sacrificed so much for our freedom
they
risked their lives for us and you know
we just wanted them to know that we're
here to support them it was a parade of
heroes in downtown las vegas as a
community cheered and thanked each
veteran for their service thousands
gathered along 4th street today after
the annual parade was canceled last year
because of the pandemic
first responders veterans and students
were among those who marched from 4th
street and gas avenue to stuart among
the supporters was donna mcdonnell who
hopes to educate her children about what
the day is all about a deep appreciation
for what our military does day in and
day out the things they see and the
things that they don't i support the
military so
i hope that they understand the
sacrifices that people make on a daily
basis but not all had the spotlight we
found francisco mcgee and his family on
the sidelines a retired firefighter who
says today is a great reminder of the
sacrifices many men and women make for
our freedom throughout the year you get
that maybe once or twice and in between
those times you see a lot of bad things
going on and then your heart gets a
little hard and then all of a sudden
somebody says appreciate your service
and it just you know softens it all up
again as a two-hour celebration wrapped
up these families are thankful this
tradition is back to remind our veterans
that they are not forgotten happy
veterans day
well several businesses are offering
deals to those who served our country
for example some restaurants are giving
out free food and drinks we have a full
list of all the freebies and discounts
available on our website 8newsnow.com